We're moving. This is our last take up video in the house.
We spent all day packing up.
Obviously, we got Thai food
always on. Having the parody is something to think about here.
We're moving all the way from Dallas to the East Coast,
but this is what we've got.
Boom,
Bing, zip.
We were so hungry today, so we got a bunch of different dishes.
Okay, so the first one we got drunken noodles with beef.
Always a classic, always good.
We always get it. So spicy.
Yes. Yeah.
Lately we've been obsessed with this dish.
It's just green beans and beef.
Lucky gets it super spicy.
I get it a level three. Out of what? Four.
This is my dish.
This one right here. Green beans,
beef,
onions,
and some juice. You see that juice?
And then my sister got Patsy,
so I'm not gonna open that.
That's hers. We obviously got some rice to go with it.
And then we got what it is.
Spicy edamame. I need your help opening this fully, please.
Thanks.
That doesn't look spicy.
Got myself a little Thai tea.
I needed to. They forgot that last time when I ordered food,
which was very tragic. And then this.
Can you open this for me, please, baby?
And then we got Tonka soup,
also very spicy. I'm feeling a little run down,
so I got this to hopefully make me feel better.
Now we are going to go eat and
relax. And stuff our faces while we indulge.
Bye, guys.